we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p this voicemail
doesn't feel so good to take a listen to
what this person has to say a david
you're a liberal hack and trump 2020
trump's gonna win nobody cares about you
and your lived on this the reality of
the situation is you're just like fox
news we love to criticize just because
they love trump but you love bernie so i
don't see the difference and i think you
should be arrested for spreading false
misinformation and also if this was
soviet russia you'd have a bully in your
[ __ ] head
well now III do under false
misinformation is that a double negative
does that mean we're spreading just
information true information
misinformation would not be accurate if
it's false misinformation maybe it is
good and the person doesn't realize it
in any case that's what we are fighting
right so as a reminder you're not going
to convince that person to vote for
anybody other than trump so don't bother
don't waste your time on it and these i
play these voicemails for you number one
just to let you know about the level of
vitriol that exists out there but number
two because these are illustrations that
we can't win we it's not a viable
strategy to say let's all go out and
convince people like that dude not to
vote for trump it's not going to happen
the focus needs to be get out the vote
prevent voter suppression prevent a
toxic destructive primary that will
actually do damage to the opportunity to
remove donald trump that is the focus
find the half of the country that
doesn't vote and talk to the people who
agree with us and make sure that they go
out and vote because the conversation
with that guy is a dead end might as
well run a motorcycle directly into a
brick wall you're not going to get
anything accomplished the focus has to
be a different one we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
DNC members who are discussing possible
rule changes at the convention to
potentially deny Bernie Sanders the
nomination if it were to come to it
secondly even insured adults who have
health insurance are increasingly going
to primary care less and less often
because of the out-of-pocket costs these
are folks with insurance we will talk
about that we will also
about the news shocking in the media
world that right-wing radio host Rush
Limbaugh says he has advanced lung
cancer immediately will be missing a lot
of his show undergoing treatment we will
discuss that and much more on today's
bonus show get access instantly by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
by becoming a patron at the $5 or
greater level at patreon.com slash david
pakman show